this is going to feel rather different
from the morning session so uh ruin will
be telling us about
evolution from a
machine learning perspective as an
analogy with
how
learning can happen versus how
dna seems to learn how to respond to the
environment
so you know
vroon is one of the
world experts in this new area of
trying to understand evolution
with this analogy um
and yeah so
very happy to have him here
thank you
um
again so please interrupt me if there's
anything which i say which is not
perfectly clear and there might be a
number of
okay so let me before i start talking
about evolution let me even begin with
machine learning
and
sort of this
no shortage of applications where
machine learning has been extremely
extremely successful right so things
like speech processing
object recognition
language translation and this there's
any number of more applications in which
machine learning has been extremely
successful
and what we find is
sort of
at a lower level all of these things
which might look as very different tasks
have
a very similar
or almost essentially the same
algorithmic techniques okay there's the
same algorithm that can be remarkably
successful in
any number of tasks which look very
different from each other
and
so and it seems like
evolution is
is also actually rather successful than
doing remarkably different things and
listeners can be
can be used
sort of what we understand in learning
to have a different look at evolution
right so
um so okay so for us so let's say
evolution by natural selection starts
with darwin and wallace and enough is
being said about
of this i won't say anything more on
that
but what i do want to talk about in this
talk is going to be
i hope
significantly different from what has
been said here so far
and
if you look at living organisms they
have
they have complex mechanisms and what do
i mean here by complex mechanisms in
particular
they operate
very differently in different
environmental conditions so they're
actually doing something that's
they look they sense their environment
and they're doing different things
in different settings
okay and the question of course
what we need to know is what we want to
answer is how does this complexity arise
and random search
maybe in the
in the genome space or whatever it is
cannot alone explain for all the
complexities
uh as we observe around us so there's
just this hasn't been enough time and
there is aren't enough resources for
random search alone to explain
why evolution has seems to have been so
successful as we think it is
right but of course darwin's theory
says that
this
is a random variation acted upon by
natural selection
and and what we're interested in is can
we quantify the notion of complexity
that can arise through these
uh through the process of random
variation and natural selection
okay
and and what's the notion of complexity
that we want to use so tomorrow i think
daniel and ian will talk about evolution
of complexity
in maybe some other ways
but for now what what i mean by
complexity is
if we look at organisms or cells or
whatever there's computing functions
there's a mathematical function that's
being realized and that's going to
capture the notion of complexity
and
hopefully things will be clearer as we
go along
so let me
look at the
picture and look at a particular
function that's going on in the cell so
so so here we have a cell and
what
think of a particular function say
expression levels of proteins
right so so we have a cell there's
all kinds of things on the cell wall
that are sensing things around it maybe
even inside the cell so there's all
kinds of sensors that are sensing the
environment
and based on what's going on around it
the cell has to decide whether a protein
should be produced or not how much of it
should be produced and so on
right so if you think of it as as a
mathematical function you can write the
quantity of protein that's produced
as a function of any number of variables
so for example this could be
think of these each of excise as
representing concentration levels of
other molecules macro or micro molecules
that are present around the cell and
that's
some combination of that should
determine
whether or not the protein should be
produced and how much of it should be
produced so this is a function that's
being computed in the cell and this
happening all the time in every living
organism
right
and and the question is
what are these functions how complex are
they and how does evolution succeed in
finding them so these are the kinds of
questions we want to think about
right
so before
go on so i want to talk about the notion
of an ideal behavior
and this could be a hypothetical entity
so think of the idea of behaviors it
would be helpful to maybe think of this
example whenever
you want to think about what i'm saying
here
so think of ideal behavior as the
optimal expression level for of a
protein for every possible environmental
conditions an environmental condition is
represented by some
numbers x1 to xn here and from each of
these settings there might be a
this
some ideal
amount of protein that should be
produced which could be zero to anything
else okay
okay and
and now we also want to know if yeah
it's a different optimal level depending
on the conditions right it's a different
optimal level depending on the condition
so so the simplest form could be either
zero or insufficient quantities
to catalyze some reactions or something
but you could imagine something else
and
and so the measure of performance is
going to be how close is the actual
function that the cell is computing so
the cell is computing some function is
very different from the ideal so how
close it is
to the ideal and so what's the notion of
close
well it depends on what kind of
values these x1 to xn can take in with
what frequency so think if
there's being some distribution over any
possible
of these variables that can be
encountered in the lifetime of a cell
and
on average the cell has to be as close
to the ideal as possible to be
to be considered better than others that
are not so this is the level of
performance of
under a particular distribution over
these possible
environmental conditions
how does the actual function computed by
a particular cell compared to the ideal
function
averaging over that distribution or
averaging the exponential
averaging over the distributions there's
a distribution over think of these as
distribution over the x size
and
i just want to i have some notion of
and so
so this performance in some sense
defines a fitness landscape for
for every different kind of function
that can be expressed by the cell this
is a different performance and
the ones that have higher performance
are more fit than the others
okay so this is
okay and
and the question that's the most
interesting interest here is so which
what kinds of functions are evolvable
this is
the question we want to try and begin to
answer
and
and the first constraints that we of
course need to
impose is that
we know that you need to be able to do
this in reasonable population sizes
because it evolution doesn't have access
to
exponentially large population sizes as
christos mentioned
this morning
and also the number of generations so
there's been
say maybe 10 to the 12 10 to the 14 or
some number of generations is a fixed we
have only so many generations
and these functions have
can we explain how the functions that we
might observe
arose in these many number of
generations so these are
the constraints that we have in the
separation
and so
i i want to emphasize again so in this
talk what we're talking about is the
evolution of genes themselves right so
so these the functions of the cell
compute is encoded in the dna that's
it's a gene somewhere and that's that
itself is changing so mutations are
essential to
understanding any of this
and so so we're not talking about
population dynamic dynamics or just i'll
have frequencies change in the
population or so these kinds of
questions so they've been discussed
in many of the previous talks so the
question what we are concerned is it is
how does complex novelty arise through
the process of evolution and can we
quantify this
yeah
let me just clarify uh from a biological
point of view when you're saying how
does complex novelty arise
what do you mean by novelty first and
second are you
okay first first first why don't you
tell me what novelty is for you
right so
okay so at some point of time you know
you had cells that were not
enjoying this kind of behavior and cells
started showing this
behavior that controlled
levels of certain proteins and that
um that gave them selective advantage
right so that's so that's a novelty so
some cells some organisms learnt that
it's actually important to produce
certain things only in certain
conditions
and as opposed to sort of always having
these
levels so you mean a new cellular
phenomena
a new cellular level
yeah so so these functions here so
are essentially phenotypes here
from regulation from regulation yeah
yeah
and so your organism is a unicellular
organism you're looking at complexity at
the level of the set
here
for now it would be fine to think of it
that way i mean this theory is not
restricted to that but it might be the
simplest way to think of it yeah
and so is it should we think of this of
your function f as being parametrized by
the genes
by the genes okay so the function itself
is is encoded in the gene okay so so the
gene represents f
f yeah so it's it's encoded in the dna
right
so it's this one
so of course there's multiple f's that
are going on in any living organism but
so let's if we're going to focus on just
one f so if selection is acting only on
a single phenotypic behavior can we
explain what complexity can arise in
this
but you're still going to look at many
possible conditions so we're still going
to look at many possible conditions so
it's still the
fitness is a complicated thing but this
is a complicated thing it's only the
single phenotype that we're talking
about single genotype not multiple ones
and what's the range of f that mapped to
boolean
for the most part i'll focus on
f being a boolean function but you can
of course let f
be real valued in high dimensional real
value it's actually paul has
very nice work in that and i'll mention
all possible so right now you can just
think of output being in some abstract
space but most of my talk will be about
boolean valued functions
this
so i mean
one way of looking at much of this is
you've got your favorite phenomenon
that's happening in some organism in
some cell or something
this organism responds to some
environment it's an unusual way
so how did this evolve could it have
evolved in one step or might or did it
need to have evolved in multiple small
steps did it need to have been trained
was it fortuitous that it arose or will
this kind of thing always predictably
easily
evolve so can we start understanding the
classes of behaviors that can easily
evolve versus the class of behaviors
that are surprising
thanks
that was
the perfect thing that
repeated at this point
so
okay so now i'm going to describe in
some detail a computational framework
for
trying to understand this question
and this is to do less valiant
so it will be helpful again to have
the first picture in mind i'm sure you
know how to spell it
okay so
so we're going to let
x
be a set that represents
environmental conditions
and typically what
we think of this as some vector in high
dimensions
so these exercise could either be
boolean or
real value so there's some high
dimensional vector that
that represents the
environmental conditions okay
think of it as those concentrations
there that i have
and this
distribution d over x
which is
one that's going to be used to compute
the performance which is
how likely
particular environment is
and
and what we want to answer is can we
characterize for what ideal functions do
we expect evolution to succeed
and for what maybe we can say argue that
evolution cannot possibly succeed in any
reasonable amount of resources right so
the idea of functions
if
we think of them as coming from a class
of functions let me call it
right
so what are some examples of ideal
functions so
so simple example if
if everything is boolean here would be
conjunctions
which says that
f of
x1 to xn is
1 and x 7 and x 13.
so this
so it can be it's a conjunction but
on some subset of the variables uh you
don't know which ones
and what you want is the function should
be one if
this holds otherwise it should be minus
one right so think of it as
over here you have
if some
concentration levels of these particular
things are high you should produce the
protein or otherwise you shouldn't
produce the protein so this is one
possible
ideal function
to consider it's kind of a
strange one in a sense because you're
just saying like you hardly ever want to
have it on the more of these
like the more of these conditions you
add the less often it should be on right
i mean like so it's not like
it's a very tricky rule to figure out
whether it's on or off just turn it off
all the time you get pretty close
uh so it depends on how long this is i
mean if there's only three or four of
them yeah yeah sure it also depends on
what the distribution over these
exercises so it doesn't have to be a
uniform distribution
maybe i'll just write one or two more so
um
so if you allow f to be
real valued
sort of
boolean we could also consider functions
that look like
some linear combination it says some
7x3
plus
4 minus 15x
so there's different classes of
functions and
some are more complex than others and
you want to try and characterize for
which classes you expect evolution to be
able to succeed in actually reaching
some such representation and for others
where you cannot can you argue that you
cannot for some other classes or
functions
okay so
so now let me define how
what an organism is going to be in this
setup so
there
you restate the definition of
performance as well
if
r from x
to say minus 1 1
is
the function that's actually computed by
by an organism
and i'll come to how we're going to
represent the knowledge
in a second
then
the performance of
r with respect to
respect to f and d that's f is ideal
function is simply the correlation
between
f
okay
and if if f and r are boolean functions
then this is
in some sense this is the only
performance metric that makes sense if
there's real value functions there might
be
several other measures that make sense
and we can talk about that later
okay so how do we represent an organism
so this is
going to be some um
so what we're going to say is that an
organism is simply a string so
so there's a class of strings that can
represent an organism so think of this
as just
strings over zeros and ones
but they also encode a function right so
think of this as a description of a
function
so
so r in r let's say
if i write it in in brackets it means
it's actually a string
and this string
that encodes a function from
function
from
say x
minus 1
okay
and
and what we want to impose on this
function is
is the fact that this can be
evaluated in polynomial time
and
what i mean by that is if
there's there's a computer program that
given say r
and x as input
outputs r of x
and this program runs in polynomial
times
yes um so we have a finite number of
variables in this boolean function
i mean
all
such functions could be expressed as
polynomials
um
say that one more time
so there's a
and so i can define functions i can
define arbitrary functions that are
that are not computable in polynomial
time right so the representation of the
function okay so the representation
itself has to be small it has to be
polynomial in n
yeah
and
and then there's
yes so there's no reason why all boolean
functions can be evaluated in polynomial
time
so
so let's say my x encodes a graph and my
function is say if it's one if it has a
hamiltonian cycle or not or something
this is it's a function on
on some input but it's not
it cannot be evaluated in polynomial
technically
okay
and
and what i want to also let me state at
this point what we think of us
is
the goal of
evolution
so there's some error parameter epsilon
and what
we want to understand this can we can
evolution reach some r
r
such that the performance of
r with respect to the ideal function is
at least one minus epsilon
are you going to evolve the
algorithm for evaluating the string in
normal time no so this algorithm is
fixed so think of once the
representation classes fix this
algorithm is fixed so we're only going
to change r so
uh
the
the question there
if i want to switch that to like given a
starting string like how well i can
improve it is that is that closely
connected or uh
like instead of is if i if i drop the
reference to the uh i say that there's
some option that's very good i don't i
don't
care too much about that but i i say
i start somewhere i want to know how
much improvement i can reasonably get
so maybe i can't reach very closely
optimally yeah okay yeah yeah okay so
what you're
asking is instead of this one minus
epsilon can we guarantee okay okay so
that's a perfectly valid question so we
think that evolution doesn't quite reach
the optimum and we want to guarantee
that can you always guarantee progress
how much how close do you expect these
so you can ask here
what access do you have to have
just you can
see so i'm going to say that in a second
so yeah so it's going to be through
natural selection and i'll describe what
how that is modelling
okay so
just just look
f is there what do you call the ideal
function yes and r is what the organism
is what organism does and and this
performance is basically the
the measure of how close they are the
performance is the measure of how close
they are
no not necessarily so everything is only
through natural selection
okay so so the next thing i'm going to
define is what
what mutations can happen to r
and
so the mutation is process is also going
to be defined with this algorithm so
this is an algorithm
it takes as input
the current representation r
and maybe this
error parameter epsilon
and it outputs
the neighborhood
which is
a number of other representations right
so each of these
ris is an r
and what do we want well first of all we
want that m is
bounded by some polynomial in n and one
over epsilon
and that this algorithm itself runs in
polynomial time so it's asexual
it's asexual
okay and so this is going to be the
definition of mutation so we don't want
to get into the business of trying to
explicitly model what this algorithm is
that evaluates r of x and how a
particular function is actually encoded
and what mutations can be
but
but we don't want to let nature have the
power to somehow
do computations that cannot be simulated
in polynomial time and get mutations
after this
okay so so think of this as allowing as
generous resources as you possibly can
for a mutation mechanism
now coming to costas questions is you
also have to
say what
selection is because so far there's no
reason why this has any access to what
the ideal function is
and that will come through selection
and
i have the definition of a performance
up there
what i also consider is
empirical performance
and
what this means is simply that
this is
the performance evaluated in the sample
it says
it's the expectation of
x i f of x i
x i going from one
like this
where x x one through x m are drawn from
this distribution excessive drop from
this distribution d over
this distribution over the possible
environmental conditions
and and the reason for doing this is
because we don't want
revolution to somehow act on extremely
tiny differences in performance so it
has to be robust enough
was there some measure of
how the ris are are
close to r or that's just the definition
so this is the definition so
so there's not some some inequality
right but but there's a fixed algorithm
that
no matter what r i give it it outputs
this mutations it's not that for diff
so so in some sense this is a fairly
permissive model that you can have
mutations that go really far from your
parents dna
so you know it's up to you guys the
audience to figure out how to interpret
this so if it's a permissive model then
impossibility results should be
especially convincing
and
so if you can't do it even in this model
where you're allowed to do really big
mutations then that should be you know
strong evidence that evolution can't
work this way i mean a big enough
mutation could end up being a
combination
you can also simulate sexual
reproduction as part of the mutation
algorithm so conversely if there's a
positive result saying well we can do
this with with under this model then you
the audience can ask well okay so
it's a subset of the model that bruno is
taking advantage of kind of you know
small enough that i view this as being
reasonable
so some of the capabilities here seem a
bit extreme so are they being used
reasonably in the positive results so
this is something for you guys to
evaluate that's talking about what do
you mean that it can
simulate
sex because it doesn't depend on the
rest of the population it's just a
function
yes it's a bit more complicated but i'm
happy to talk to you after the
discussion
as far as existence and what the goal so
the you is the top part of the argument
going to be that there exists these
algorithms for the string and for the
mutation algorithm um such that things
can happen or is it under relatively
general um uh class of those
that certain things can't happen right
so this is okay so that's what i guess
follows
so we want to have both kinds of results
so we want to do a lot certain classes
of functions and we think even with this
you don't expect evolution to succeed in
getting any very close to ideal for
those
function classes on the other hand you
know you can show that for some classes
you can achieve this and then it's it's
a very valid question is this
are these
the mutation algorithm that we define
and these are are they something that
you would ever expect to
observe in nature and what can we what
does that tell us about this right so
okay so
so let's just
i'm going to notice denote this by a
performance hat
and so the way selection works is
the following
so for each of the
possible mutations and for r itself
we have this
approximate performance
and then we can define what which among
them are beneficial
which is
all right such that
performance of
i is greater than
the performance of r and i'm going to
put
a tolerance factor here so it's not just
that it's better but it's some somewhat
noticeably better
and the neutral mutations
of those
for which
this the difference between performances
is
basically
within this tolerance
and the rest are dedicated
right
okay so this is
so the question is that why do we need
to go to empirical performance this is
supposed to performances
um
it's
it's also
so one thing is this is a you okay so
certainly you don't want
sort of
very small differences in the
performance to affect
evolution in any way so if it's
infinitesimally smaller than this then
you don't necessarily want to let
evolution actually so there's some noise
inherent in the system right so even
with this tolerance
um
it's the process of which mutation is
beneficial and which is not it's it
should not be defined by arbitrarily
small performance differences
yeah it
foreign
so it turns out that
some of these questions don't matter as
much so you can show robustness results
that you can define them in
several different ways and all of them
lead to the same notion of evolvability
but for now think of it as each state
when you're considering one mutation
selection step you draw a fake sample
and then you evaluate all of all of
these representations on the same sample
but the robustness doesn't come from
like
some concentration
that would allow me to as well replace
all these empirical things with the
exact thing right so
um okay so the robustness so a lot of
the robustness results can be proved by
this reduction that vitali has from
learning algorithms to evolution and
then
because sort of we have we know that if
evolution can be stimulated by certain
class of learning algorithms and all of
them can be put in
this framework then you get the
basically they define the same class of
functions that can be evolved
but it's the answer is yes but yeah yeah
okay
okay and so
so what selection does is now is
right there but
i don't want to erase this
either so let me get rid of this
so the selection rule is
if
the set of beneficial mutations is not
empty
are primed
in
random
if this is
empty and neutral mutations is not empty
pick r prime in the neutral mutations
okay and this is
so r prime is going to be
r prime survives to the next generation
and
like the
question of robustness here there's some
robustness that you can also
ask about selection rules for example
you can ask what happens if you let
evolution
select the one that has
the best performance and all of these
and things like that so there's a few
more subtle points there but
by and large a lot of those
selection rules give rise to the same
notion of
i guess obviously whether this is an
individual and you're keeping a lot of
diversity in the population or is this a
sweep that goes through the population
and so after this step you only have one
so after this step you have only one so
okay so this is this generation whatever
need not be one by logical generation
but right this is what ultimately
successfully for something invitation
comes in
exactly
yes
okay which is a very restrictive
condition
essentially small population
restrictive meanings
meaning things
oh you've got a factor of 10 to the 30th
better than you can
i mean there's very large number of
individuals
and the some things that
can't happen here
but
all this is a polynomial time
restrictions the question is can you or
can you not do this in polynomial time
so factors of even 10 to 30 are still
constant
so you need to put you put on your
theoretical group your scientific
10 to 30 is a constant but since you
already raised 15 minutes ago with the
issue about you know which things you
should take away right then that's a
planet
yeah
is this so i mean there are other
results about sort of trade-offs between
if you add more population to this model
how much does it let you reduce the
number of generations
okay
um the last thing i'm going to need to
define in this whole setup is now what
we actually do mean by evolvability
and
right so one one step of evolution is
with this mutation plus selection
maybe you start with a representation r
you have
a bunch of possible mutations
and one of them is selected for the next
generation
in the selection rule
and
try to be fairly formal than actually
writing the definitions
we're going to say is that we set
a class of functions
so functions say f
is
with respect to fixed distribution d
over x
if
there exists a representation class r
a mutation algorithm
these
so this
size functions and tolerance i didn't
talk much about them but
the requirement on s is it has to be at
most a polynomial in n and one over
epsilon and t should be at least an
inverse polynomial in in n and one over
epsilon so what is the representation
clause
so okay so unfortunately erased that but
this was um so so so each representation
is just a string and it also encodes a
function and the requirement is that it
can be computed in polynomial
such that
and so this is for every every f in
f
every epsilon greater than 0
and for every
r 0 in r
the sequence
r 0 r
1
g where each
ri is obtained from ri minus 1 so this
process
is
such that
with high probability
performance of
rg is at least 1 minus epsilon
and g is
bounded by some polynomial in n l 1 over
x
let you pass this for a couple of
seconds please
right
but
the crucial points to point out here and
so the requirement is that you know this
is
once we fix the class of functions the
class of representations and a mutation
process and no matter what the ideal
function is from this class
um and for some for any
error parameter epsilon and for any
starting representation in this class
that you've picked
if you allow evolution to proceed as
according to this mutation algorithm and
detection rule eventually you will reach
a representation which has high
performance in a reasonable number of
generations
yes
so this condition that it's for all
possible ads is
quite strong
so are there other
notions that you know for particular
classes of
so so so that means you're restricting
the class of function so yeah right so
so once you fix your class of functions
you want to talk about whether that is
evolvable
this should work for every function in
that class so for example i i have
conjunctions up here so for all possible
conjunctions is to succeed
if you if you could restrict the class
you should say only for maybe short
conjunctions and that's a perfectly
valid statement but then you would have
to make the statement that short
conjunctions are evolvable
but once you fix your class you should
be able to prove this kind of person as
well
okay so that was a lot of definitions so
so i'm going to try to do one particular
class of functions and give an
evolutionary algorithm for that
so hopefully
some of this makes
a lot more sense and then in the second
dots after the break i'll actually show
that there's a cluster functions that
probably cannot be evolved
okay so this class of functions is
this selection
so this is going to be evolving
simple linear threshold functions
so let me fix
x
x is just r n
and the distribution
is let's say
this
is a product normal distribution so the
spherical gaussian distribution over rn
right and your class of functions f
is the form the f is
sine of
w dot x
where w is
is a vector in our in normal w is one
okay so what are these
functions of let's say this is
space
so essentially half planes that pass
through the origin so this is my cluster
function so all of these are say plus
one all of these are minus one
and i could choose
any direction and choose a half plane in
that direction so this is
this is the class of functions that i'm
looking at each one is classified by a
character by single omega uh it's each
one is characterized
right so
okay so now i need to define a
representation class
and so the representation class is
actually going to be
f itself so this
so this is
i'm going to use
again each representation is going to be
characterized by this vector omega which
defines some direction which may be
different from
now let me define the mutations
so i guess i don't understand what you
mean by representation being a function
okay so so that somebody represents so
so my r that represented the function
that the organism was computing is from
the same class as this so i i so each w
defines what the function the organism
is computing
right so and and which is this function
so i also think of each
okay
so each r is some
w1 through wn and
this computes a function which is
exactly
r of x sine of this
so the picture in two dimensions is a
bit simpler so let me just draw that
so what we're
saying now here is that suppose
there's some ideal function so there's
some ideal function from this class
which is
represented by this red vector
so this is f star
and
and you start with some arbitrary
representation w in this space and you
want to
give a mutation algorithm that changes
to
to this
vector w will eventually get you
arbitrary close to f star so that's
what we'll do
so what's the mutation algorithm
and i'm going to leave
some of this as an exercise maybe um
so let's
start with w so this takes
input the current representation r which
is represented by w
and epsilon
w
mu one three u n minus one
form
the normal basis for
rn
underd
the neighborhood of
w
is simply going to be
w
cos theta
plus
plus or minus ui sine theta
for i
n
this one for theta chosen appropriate
okay so before
i say anything more on that so what are
we saying here
really so let's say this was your ideal
function f star maybe you started with
w somewhere here
um what we're going to make changes to w
is by allowing it to
move slightly in any direction around it
so so no large jumps but
some cone around w where it can move
in any way
and and one of them is going to be in a
direction that's going to be noticeably
closer to the ideal functions than
than what w originally was
uh no it depends on epsilon and n
yeah
so once epsilon fixed it's fixed
and
for the neighborhood distribution
so w has to be one of them and then you
can choose any other normal basis
normal basis will
give you
some neighbor that's actually going to
be
have significantly better performance
than
what
so there are orthogonal with respect to
this measure on narration
wait i mean this would just be
orthogonal in our normal yeah okay so
because it's a normal distribution it's
just yeah it is
yeah even standard bases but i think w
has to be one of them and then no
yeah yeah maybe okay maybe even yeah
okay so yeah even the standard basis
should i think work here
so
it's okay so i don't want to actually do
the calculations but if anyone is
interested you can so wait is the u.s
fix for each step or is it
you can change it again
so so they can be chosen differently it
doesn't matter so you can fix uis i
think you're really such as standard
bases ahead of time or
you have w and then you have n minus one
more dimension just choose any
orthonormal basis in the remaining
dimensions that you like and
so any of these things will work and so
so one of the advantages here is that
this this is fairly robust to the kind
of mutations that you use
and
and hopefully at the end of the next
talk i would like to have some
discussion what kinds of mutation
algorithms are more reasonable than
others
or not and can is there any intelligent
way to say why some mutation algorithms
are better than others or not
even ten random vectors chosen random
vectors chosen will be five yeah
okay and sort of the main thing
thing to use here is that
would be helpful is
that the performance of this
is basically related to the angle
between w and f star so your performance
is nothing but
the angle over say
is the performance of w
is simply anything theta over
it's
because it's
so w classifies all of these as positive
f classifies all of these as positive
um
and what you have is anything that lies
in between is where w and f disagree so
that's so the performance is just
related the angle between them
and
using elementary trigonometric
inequalities gives you a fact that this
these kind of mutations will actually be
succeeded
it's not just that it's a
one-dimensional function it's also it's
a very nicely behaved one if you made it
like w dot x bigger than a third
yeah so it's a so for this particular
thing it's critical that you're looking
at thresholds that pass through the
origin but does it depend on the
tolerance because we might expect that
if the tolerance
if the
weekly deleterious ones that you allowed
were without too many of those that the
neutral mutations coming in would drive
you away from the other one
so it does depend on tolerance you need
to tune the tolerance
correctly
but these so
okay so these these kinds of mutation
algorithms are actually such that if you
choose your tolerance correctly you can
actually guarantee that there's always a
beneficial mutation and that's that's
not always the case
but
in this case it is and which means that
you can set the tolerance to a
reasonable inverse polynomial and
you will get that this succeeds in
actually reasonably small number of
generations
which mutation that would you fix you
pick a given number of of possible
mutations in this neighborhood yes so
the same parameter which is how many um
yeah
i'll take any more questions but
otherwise this will be a good time to
stop and then after the break i'll
i'll talk a bit more about
learning theory and then show how that
can be used to show that they're
actually functions that cannot be
evolved in this
setup